can i borrow someone's phone can i just
borrow a phone
i know it's okay i hear i'll get one
there you go
okay i just want to show you something
i'm just going to show you a little i'm
just going to
okay
i'm just going to show you something
right
so
um
i'm just holding my phone while i'm
talking to you guys uh it's not buzzing
it's not beeping i'm not checking it i'm
just holding it let me just ask you a
question do you feel like you're the
most important thing to me right now
exactly there's a deep-seated
psychological reaction
when you were walking around a house
with a client holding your phone even if
you're not checking it
and i have absolutely had it where i've
been walking around with an agent and
they're talking to me and then i like
look to the left and i turn around and
they're like this
guess how that made me feel
that i am not the most important thing
to that person in this moment wow right
and this is and this is artificial i'm
just doing it right now in front of a
room and i'm not even looking down and
you don't feel that special
right so
uh the point is is put your phone away
for the 10 minutes you're walking around
a house
and you go ahead
uh
the
i mean like like the the art of making
someone feel seen unheard is
stupidly simple
right
uh uh
learning their name really quickly is
really easy and calling them by their
name is really easy asking them
questions not about what they're looking
for in a house but asking questions
about who they are like where they see
themselves in five years professionally
like you know are you married single
what do you know what do you learn about
them as if you know
as as people
and all of that learning
makes you show people different things
it makes you it makes you creative
i know this wasn't the kind of house you
were looking for but based on what we
talked about before i think you really
like this
and now you're not looking to sell them
a house you're looking to sell them a
home and i know a lot of you use those
terminology i'm not here to help you
find a house i'm here to find a home and
yet you still left a bottle of champagne
in the in the fridge
in their new house
you didn't help them make a home with a
yoga mat
um
uh so
uh
really really easy put put put your
devices away because not only does it
distract us but as an act of service